the doctor says this will make you feel
better
yeah if you can sleep of course you can
sleep sitting like this guy with your
eyes open
i still say malaria doesn't kill you
like hell it doesn't no local of mine
had it in scranton had it for 40 years
in his bones and out it came every three
years the day after christmas yeah too
much christmas booze that's all don't
give me that
you'll play
uh-huh
oh jesus you're slow oh shut up
i said it was your play
okay okay
here how's this
what a jerk
dr bush wants to see you lucas
oh for christ's sake now what'd you do
okay
good luck
come in
this is lucas sir
sit down lucas
thank you sir
figure it out
you know lucas i've been wondering about
you
during the week that you've been here
i've noticed that unlike the other men
you don't talk in our group sessions
what is it a talk about sir
lots
you hear the other men getting quite a
few things off their chests you should
be able to see that they feel better by
so doing
what ship were you on lucas
the montanan sir
the montana was sunk wasn't she yes sir
last may south of mindanao and a high c
torpedo aft
and you were a fireman
and sir
certainly and it's a tough job being a
fireman always below decks you never see
what goes on
that's why i'm fed up nobody gets it
nobody
maybe not and yet there may be some of
us even among those of us who haven't
been there who do understand
what do you sir know about what it feels
like to be a fireman
well does anybody know what it feels
like to be a farm and accept a fireman
you got to be there to know you got to
feel that goddamn heat
on the montana it was always 128 degrees
below decks
128 degrees of sweat and more sweat
no place to go and i'll move to
those guys top side have it soft they
can breathe air move around see the
enemy hell we don't know whether the
next minute will bring a bomb or whether
there's a torpedo coming for us right
now
what was your job in the engine room
lucas i was striving for water tender i
watched the lines feeding water to the
boilers that's why i couldn't move i had
to stay with those god damn valves
guys topside and take it out in the
enemy they can shoot a gun
all i could do was wish i could twist a
valve but i couldn't because i'd wrecked
the boiler
christ you get so you got to do
something and all you end up with is a
burning feeling in your guts and your
hands shaking
god damn it look at me
this isn't me doctor
how did you feel lucas when you knew you
were safe in the water how did i feel
yes
i was damn glad to get out of that hole
anybody would have been
no lucas not everybody would have been
that's something you've got to face
furthermore you didn't really find
relief did you
i said i was glad to get out of that
hole
perhaps for a while
but i doubt it for long
how about it lucas
how about it
no sir
i got the feeling i let my buddies down
that's it lucas
and that's something you've got in a way
to feel proud of
you were in a tight tense situation and
quite naturally you were afraid
you and every other man on that ship
your buddies in the engine room the
gunners top side you were all afraid
because that's what happens to men in a
battle
you were no different from any other man
on that ship
only most of them accepted their fear
you fought against yours
if i only could have been topside if i
could only have moved around it would
have made no difference
you see you let your fear get control of
you
you wanted to get out of the engine room
that's why you felt relieved when you
were in the water
even though you'd been blown from the
engine room as far as you were concerned
you had escaped
in your mind you felt that you deserted
your buddies your ship
as a result you feel guilty
yes sir that's a feeling that you have
to face and conquer and the only way you
can do that is to understand that the
real cause of your being here is your
normal fear and time of battle
fear which you didn't learn to handle
properly
that you're continuously short-tempered
even mean
that your hands shake you have a burning
sensation in the pit of your stomach
all stem from this cause
now in order to start getting well you
have to realize this
and in realizing it remember that fear
and the thoughts that it makes you think
at the time are normal
nothing to be ashamed of
shared by all of the other men who were
with you on the mountain as well as by
the men on all ships
so you told me i was scared
that's not what's wrong with me what to
be scared of around here gee fella
something's the matter what is it i
don't know i don't get it it seems like
i'm always mad and running off of the
mouth but how can being scared when the
japs are shooting at you make you such a
bastard after you gotten back the
doctors tell us when a fella gets that
way it's because he fights being afraid
instead of trying to do something about
it
how the hell are you going to do
anything about it when your job just
standing there twisting a little valve
my job the same sort of thing in a
battle i'm not shooting a gun either
but i know when i got scared and thought
how much i'd like to be someplace else i
used to think
all the other guys are too
but they're doing their job and i'm
doing mine and between us we're giving
the enemy a hell of a licking
same thing goes for you
your job was important
you had to do it so the guys in the
turrets could fire the guns and so guys
like me could take care of the wounded
you got to work your feelings off that
way by figuring it's a whole ship that's
fighting
and since you're part of the crew you're
fighting too
at least that's the way i look at it
yeah i know i used to feel that way
sometimes what's it got to do with me
being on edge all the time and wanting
to smash things
and you know it gets worse when i came
back first i wasn't so bad and i saw
these guys sitting around at that desk
shining their pants gold bricking
i thought what me and my buddies have
been through and
well that's what got me started
did you ever stop and think that maybe
those fellas didn't want to be sitting
at desks
maybe they were there because they were
told to be
don't give me that they like it
they like shoving us around the yellow
bellies
i hadn't been at that relocation center
more than two hours before i got wise to
them
come on come on claire the gangway
you're not allowed to stand around here
oh we're just waiting for small stores
to open i don't care what you're waiting
for get going for christ's sake mate
what kind of a navy is this if you don't
start moving along silly you'll be
finding out
yeah it was just one little thing after
another
hell do this do that
hey sailor square that hat hey what do
you think i am a boot squad
in case you don't know this is a todd
ship
a hot ship
looks to me as if we've run aground
skipper
by the way do you know there's a war
going on
i'm sorry but there's nothing we can do
until the bureau sends us an adjusted
pay account you mean because i was dumb
enough to get myself torpedoed i can't
get paid oh it won't take long you've
only been here two days
don't you people ever think of anything
but your little pieces of paper i'm
sorry but you must remember there were a
thousand men on your ship that's a big
pay list to clear up besides are
scattered all over the country now look
sister i got a 30-day leave i need
spending money then you can go to the
chaplain of the welfare office
go to the
oh
thanks sister i'll be seeing you
well it just doesn't make any sense they
want you to square your hat they won't
let you stand in line not even in line
yeah cause if nothing were different
well we can keep our noses clean without
them telling us
uh-huh
the boy's gotta have something to do
holding you down helps fill up the idle
hour yeah well thank god i got this
leave coming up and maybe afterwards
i'll send me back to a ship where i can
feel like myself again
maybe i can get away from these gold
bricks that have nothing to do all day
but order us guys around telling us to
square our hats
i'd like to see them out there
i'd like to see how square an sp's hat
is with a hundred jack planes dive
bombing them
that's the way i felt that's the way i
feel yet that means i'm crazy all right
i'm crazy
they don't understand us back here god
damn civilians
if they knew what it's like being asleep
in a foxhole and having a [ __ ] land on
your back and how to fight it out with
him with a knife
i don't think they'd stay home so often
on mondays the damn right
i guess you're all proving how irritable
you are this morning
don't think we like it i'm sure you
don't
one of the unfortunate things about
being bad tempered and quick to take
offense is that you cut yourself off for
most people
now there's one thing to get straight
right away
all of these attitudes of yours
your hatred of the land-going navy of
civilians and so on are all symptoms of
your illness and their symptoms for
which we must find the cause it's
because square in your head is of no
importance that it gets you not at all
the reason you're annoyed by such petty
matters lies in your basic condition
you know that before the war before you
experienced the tension and the fear of
battle
you weren't annoyed by such things
as i told you before
your natural fears in battle were not
properly handled
you didn't accept them as a part of
living
the necessary part of fighting
you held them in choke them back until
they finally overpowered you
you still have those fears
and it's from them that these
irritations arise then why are we
allowed to leave the hospital if they
just let us go home get away from
military life we'd forget it we'd snap
out of it lucas did you go on that
30-day leave you were talking about
yes sir
how come
i wasn't sick yet
at least they hadn't caught up with me
how was it lucas
it was lousy
in what way was it lousy
i know what you're driving that and
that's exactly what it was like
as a matter of fact if i hadn't gotten
that leave i probably wouldn't be here
now
to tell the truth it was damn nice to
get home
mother and dad were at the train and so
was sue
she and i got engaged before i joined up
she'd been my girl in high school
anyway i was glad to see them
then over two years
you know that did it was something just
the way i thought it would be want some
more coffee bob yeah
it's more ice cream dogs lots left gosh
no
better hat bob puts hair on your chest
well you used to laugh at it
yeah
flesh
female flesh
bloody soft pinky coffee
oh is it wonderful dad
the children here together again
bob and two
just like old times
just like it used to be
well that sure was some chow mom
almost as good as navy ciao only uh you
should have had some beans but you know
bob i was so excited having you home i
was afraid i'd forget articles you sure
didn't i'll say you didn't
goodness
well bob would you like mother and me to
go to a movie
oh no
no we should all be together this first
evening bob will walk me home later well
we we could easily go
oh mother we have much gas left anyway
you never know how rationing has tied us
down
so dad only gets an a book
now you know how i've tried martha it's
just that bill thomas
oh he's chairman of the rationing board
now and he's never forgotten how i quit
his darn factory
guys that's been 15 years ago too i
guess it is sort of tough with just an a
book yeah i don't say it is
i just can't believe you're here bob
sitting there with you mother that's
about the tenth time you said that
i'm sorry
bert haskins is home got home just the
other day
hey that's swell what's he on a furlough
well yes he's just back from germany
say what's wrong with all of you anyway
you're not the same you're treating me
as if i were a stranger
oh sorry
maybe you're right bob you are a bit of
a stranger
oh i mean you've been lots of places and
seeing the
well the sort of thing we've never seen
that's all it is boss
yes sir we've got a lot of ground to
cover before we're all caught up and
there's things happened here for you to
find out about too oh
we haven't been exactly standing still
well i should say not
why we've got one of the biggest
factories in the country here
and we're not supposed to tell what they
make
only 50 000 people know it's tanks
well it's brought more new people to
town things are terribly overcrowded now
let's let bob do the talking he can find
out about these things tomorrow after
all it's not everybody who's been to sea
for 18 months
was it really bad i mean all the time no
no of course not usually we're just
moving from one place to another pneuma
guam moresby all those stinking little
places
tell me bob what has happened i mean
when the ship sank with the sharks
shut up shut up all of you
even before i was out of the house i was
ashamed of myself
i had that burning feeling in my stomach
and my hands were shaking
i think i know why now but then i didn't
why lucas
it brought me back by the questions of
those god damn valves and i was all
wound up and scared all over again
i was too scared to know that that's
what it was i i really thought that they
didn't understand me anymore
well
anyway they should have known better
than to ask me those questions
that being scared is certainly part of
it lucas
anyway i walked the streets for a hell
of a long time trying to figure it out
but i didn't
i just felt lower and lower by the
minute
i couldn't get them
i couldn't get myself so i decided to
pin one on
brother did i
give me another
there you've had most of it
finish it
smart guy huh
what's eating your sailor
not a goddamn
thing this your hometown sir
yeah
been home long
this afternoon
oh got a fight with your girl huh
no
have you got a girl
been away a long time haven't you
christ how many more questions you got
hell it's near closing time you're the
last customer i just assumed talk well i
wouldn't
lots of places haven't you
and yes
what's that first ribbon for
that's the continental area
it's the one the goldbricks wear
what have you got it on for
christ you got me
that's a good one
what's the middle ribbon
that's for africa this is the pacific
the one with the stars in it
never getting shot at
a lot of america
i'll say there are
plenty of shells behind them too
hey are you making fun of me
hello
yourself
go home sailor make it up with somebody
is it your family or is it your girl
has your change
so i went home
so
from then on it was all downhill little
things got me
one night i was waiting for sue to get
dressed we had a date
our kid brothers were in the room play
jesus larry watch out
so
i was only really happy when i was with
those of the old gang who would come
back particularly with bert haskins who
lost an armada
they hadn't told me that first night
i thought they'd spare my feelings
well i'll tell you us guys that know got
to stick together and i was thinking
when enough of us get back we can rent a
place like that old vacant store room
down on market street and have a club of
our own yeah i can start working on it
right now why not good idea i'll call
tom against tomorrow he's good at
raising money you know folks we've got
something there we could sit around
shooting the breeze have a bar throw
parties
could be a place of our own
but it was with sue that it was the real
trouble we just couldn't hit it off
anymore
god knows we tried
it was all right when we couldn't talk
there is
death lays his eyes
but later after church it was different
it's hard to think what it's like in
summer
leaves in the trees and hot and
thunderstorms
remember when we used to smile here's
mini roasting
yeah i wonder what's happened to that
old hay wagon that old voice it was
wonderful riding that wagon all i was
seeing
and there was always a moon wasn't it
seems that way
a long time ago not so long
back to senior year in high school
the time that we were swimming right
over there
we supposed to be in the water
silly place to ask a girl to marry you
well i tried everywhere else
plus you were stubborn we were too young
and you knew it
you never said that then
no
maybe i just knew it without realizing
it
i don't get you so it should have
happened
i thought we've missed we'll have it
darling it won't be very much longer
we can start all over again come back
here with a gang have a weenie roast and
go swimming husband haskins going to go
swimming how do you know how many of the
old gang will be around including me
i'm sure you'll be here
i must be sure that
oh stop kidding yourself sue don't you
know what this is all about don't you
know we can't go back no i don't
i know that we've got to feel the way we
did about each other our marriage won't
work
you've got to get a hold of yourself bob
ever since you've been home you've been
snapping at me all for god's sake sue
you just don't understand anymore you've
changed
go on home sue i want to be by myself
i never felt so low in my life as when i
walked away from her
but there was nothing else i could do
for the next couple days i hung around
the house i was nervous and felt half
sick
dad got the idea it might do me good to
go hunting
at first it was fine dad and i used to
hunt a lot
i'd always like to hunt i had a sweet
gun
i don't know it seemed good to be off in
the woods with the old man
i felt pepped up
you skirt the woods here bob i'll go in
and see what i can flush okay
don't shoot me by mistake now i'm no
rabbit
okay
foreign
christ
for christ's sake what to bring me out
of here for god dammit god damn it god
so dad took me to the doctor
he said something about my nerves and
called the red cross
the red cross called the navy
and that's that
no brother don't want to go home
don't want to go home until you're well
the thing i don't understand is why did
lucas get all hard and bothered about a
rabbit he didn't have to fire a gun in
combat
do you know why lucas no sir
lucas
tell the class again about that
torpedoing
potatoing yes
how did you feel when you were in the
water
i told you over and over again for god's
sake i felt glad glad i was out of that
ship
is that all yes yes yes
i don't think so or you wouldn't be so
excited about it well it is god damn it
is i tell you it is
lots of them were dying all around me
easy now lucas
we all understand
it takes a lot out of you to face bitter
unpleasant memories
come inside with me
i'll be back in a moment
come over here and lie down lucas
to say all that takes
guts as difficult as it was to do so
much easier will it be from now on
you can't dislodge deep-seated sensitive
feelings without hurting
you feel better shortly
yeah take this it'll help you relax
now just rest for a bit
we'll talk about it later when you feel
easier
you'll feel much better when you wake up
i'll be back
now let's get some things straight
it took a lot out of lucas to tell that
story he's a better man for doing it
every one of you must go through a
similar realization
of what lies behind symptoms regardless
of what they are
irritability bad dreams vomiting
no matter where you fought
on land in the air or on a ship or a sub
you have to face those memories get them
out in the open exactly as lucas has
done
now let's consider the whole problem
but first clements
you see now why lucas got so hot and
bothered about a rabbit of all things
well
maybe the moment he raised his gun the
rabbit seemed to disappear
and he saw his mates again
drowning dying in the water all around
him
sure it's just like that feeling that i
got when i watched my body die
that's it what are the simple basic
facts
it's quite clear from what we know of
lucas that he was a happy man before
this whole business started
sort of a fellow who might run a
successful garage or store
like well thought of in his hometown
he wasn't irritable bad tempered with a
chip on his shoulder quite contrary
he was easy to meet easy to know a good
guy
and what
for 18 months he's at sea there's
nothing unusual about that
thousands of men have done as much or
more
but lucas is tied down to valves he's
never completely a part of the crew
he doesn't feel that he and the gunners
and ships cooks and the boys in cic are
all one
no he feels that he's just a little
apart just a little special
wanting to
well what
wanting to hurl himself at a jack whom
he'll surely kill
wanting to shoot down a plane
wanting to do anything except stay where
he is and do his job in keeping the ship
going and fighting
because he can't do what he thinks he
wants to do
or what he thinks he ought to do he gets
all tied up in knots
the same time he's scared
scared just to you and every other man
is scared when your lives are at stake
but lucas wants his own kind of personal
release for that fear
he doesn't realize that the torpedomen
and the gunners the bridge he himself
all have to work together to bring down
that jab plane to blow up that [ __ ] dd
it isn't a one-man job
and one man can't get rid of his fear at
the expense of others
especially when they're all in the same
boat
this wanting to do something that isn't
his job is his manner of running away
only he can't
the ship and his conscience both have
him tied down to those valves
then fate steps in and gives him what he
wants
as a result he's happy safe in the water
blown out of his problem
and then he sees the crew
his buddies burning drowning dying
and he feels that his safety is somehow
a part of their misery their deaths
he feels that because deep down he did
want to escape
he is therefore in a way responsible for
their predicament
there you have the facts
but what can lukas do about them
what's done is done you can't erase
that what he should do is to accept
these feelings understand them and
discipline them
but he doesn't
instead he becomes touchy fed up
confused and mean
look what happened to him
when he first returned he didn't seem
different
calm on the surface
nobody could tell that something was
gnawing at him fighting inside
but as the days went on so did his
fighting
he got worse and worse
then when he got home on leave he lashed
out at those he loved because they
reminded him of his feeling of guilt of
unworthiness by asking him simple
natural questions about his experiences
he fought against and left the girl he
loved
and i'm sure you all realize that he
still loves her
because he felt that she no longer
understood him
well how could she
she only knew him but what he said and
did
why he didn't even understand himself
what you have just witnessed has changed
him started him toward a real
understanding
he can now realize that all that
disconnected fed up feeling which showed
itself as a fighting bad temper
comes from something underneath
from a feeling of guilt
feeling of unworthiness
feeling which he twisted about so that
it looked as though everyone else were
in the wrong
everyone but lucas himself
that's why we have these group
discussions
to help you and lucas see yourselves as
others see you and to see problems like
yours that other men have
furthermore you and lucas can now put
your new knowledge to use in a variety
of constructive ways
occupational therapy will provide lucas
with a profitable physical outlet for
his feelings
it will teach him that he can work while
solving his problems and do a better job
of both
and physical training will help keep him
in shape in the meanwhile
what goes for lucas goes for you
or your irritation is only a symptom
a symptom of feelings which you've
buried or tried to deny
like insomnia or being depressed or
sulky or believing that you're no good
bad temper is a sign of something
something deeper
something which has to be faced and
understood and worked out
when you can do with your problems what
lucas has done with his
you will be free of all your symptoms
you